With Avengers: Infinity War set to bring together
story arcs from almost 20 Marvel movies over
the past decade, there's no denying the sheer
force and influence of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
But it wasn't always smooth sailing.
Marvel's first misstep was Iron Man 2, which
lacked the finesse fans would eventually come
to expect.
Here's how one of the franchise's least-liked
movies almost derailed the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
Weak and clunky
One of the most scattered and unfocused films
in the MCU, Iron Man 2 is essentially two
movies crammed into one.
We begin with Tony Stark coming to grips with
not just his newfound superhero status, but
the fact that the arc reactor in his chest
is slowly poisoning him.
But wait!
There's an old diorama made by Tony's father
Howard that holds the key to a new element
that just so happens to be the exact material
Tony needs to save his life—and it just
gets sillier from there.
"It tastes like coconut… and metal."
Between scattered action set pieces and bizarre
side stories, there are also the easter eggs.
The early days of the MCU saw the studio dropping
in nods and references that didn't feel completely
organic to the stories the films were telling.
One of the biggest rotten eggs is the prototype
Captain America shield that's laying around
in Stark's workspace, which just feels like
an unnecessary Marvel geekout.
Too much, too fast
Tasked with following up the surprising success
of Iron Man, the deck was arguably stacked
against Iron Man 2.
This sequel was also the last chance of the
MCU to lay some groundwork for The Avengers.
Black Widow, Nick Fury and Agent Coulson were
written into supporting roles to establish
the parts they'd eventually play in The Avengers.
"I've got my eye on you."
With Iron Man dealing with a personal crisis
and a bad guy, it felt forced to see Nick
Fury waving from the sidelines, trying to
shoehorn in the fact that there's a bigger
world out there when we hadn't even met half
of the Avengers yet.
It was a classic example of show, don't tell—and
Iron Man 2 did a lot of telling.
"Sir, I'm gonna have to ask you to exit the
donut."
Plans changed
Though he's since been replaced by Taika Waititi,
Joss Whedon, and Shane Black, director Jon
Favreau helped lay the groundwork for the
MCU fans know and love today.
As the director of Iron Man, he used his passion
and talent to establish a tone that would
carry on through more than a dozen subsequent
movies.
Favreau also had his own ideas mapped out
for an Iron Man trilogy, planning to explore
the "Demon in a Bottle" storyline from the
comics, which focused on Stark's alcoholism.
However, Marvel wanted a more "family-friendly"
approach.
"There's the door!"
It seems Favreau may have had more storytelling
freedom in the early days—back before Marvel
realized Iron Man was their golden goose.
Marvel's villain problem
Almost every Marvel movie has a problem when
it comes to their bad guys.
Marvel puts great thought into its heroes,
but their evil foils often leave much to be
desired.
Looking back, we can trace the origin of the
MCU's villain problems to Iron Man 2.
Mickey Rourke is one heck of a talented actor,
a fact that made his one-note performance
as Ivan Vanko, a gruff Russian thug, all the
more frustrating.
"I don't know if you know this, but I don't
speak Russian!"
Rourke says he wanted to add
"...other layers and colors, not just make
this Russian a complete murderous revenging
bad guy."
According to him, though, a good chunk of
his performance wound up on the cutting room
floor.
Considering how much Marvel was trying to
cram into this movie, it's not a surprise
that Vanko's story was cut short.
But it still makes you wonder what could've
been.
There was also Vanko's partner, Justin Hammer.
In the comics, Hammer was a legitimate corporate
rival to Tony Stark.
In Iron Man 2, he's little more than a punchline,
leading to an awkward pairing of slapstick
and menace that was one of the weakest aspects
of an already weak film.
Instead of one quality villain, Iron Man 2
gave us two subpar ones.
"They're $125.7M a pop, so…
OH GOSH!"
The sequel trap
When it comes to making a sequel, most studios
try to go bigger and badder, and Iron Man
2 fell into that same formula.
It had more characters, more team-ups, bigger
set pieces, and wackier villains.
Put simply: Iron Man 2 tried to go too big
too fast.
Following the film's release, Robert Downey,
Jr. admitted they may have tried too hard
to make the film bigger rather than making
it good.
There's little doubt that this problem was
exacerbated by all the heavy lifting to lay
the groundwork for The Avengers.
Iron Man 2 had the deck stacked against it
from the start.
Is it good?
Marvel Studios is at the top of Hollywood
these days, but back when Iron Man 2 arrived,
it was still figuring out how to make all
these big movies while keeping the quality
level high.
Iron Man 2 hasn't aged well, either.
As Collider notes:
"The film feels rushed, bloated, unsteady,
and unfocused."
"It's a perfect example of everything NOT
to do."
It still made a ton of money at the box office,
but there's no doubt some fans were turned
off by its convoluted plot, zany bad guys,
and excessive foundation-laying.
Marvel learned a lot from this movie, and
these lessons likely helped Marvel make The
Avengers such a crowd-pleaser, but we all
had to watch this dud to get there.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!